[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about the very popular comments
they're floating around my comment
section it's about like blood points or
the final season many of you seem to
think it might be real so let's take a
look at it
the common read spoiler alert all Aryan
still swords have all been engraved in
Valyrian with instructions on how to end
long night which are pieces of a poem
each sword forged in the Iron Throne has
instruction so how to prevent a long
night by working together Ned he dawn
inside of the unturned with other swords
and it will be shown in a flashback
hiding the sword before Robert storms in
Menna fella no full-blooded star except
the perished and long night for good
them showing Winterfell burning was an
actual league from the showrunners
Winterfell burning will be in the last
episode not the third Ezreal thought the
night King knows the dawn has the final
piece of the poem to end along night
he's looking for the sword to destroy it
so he can exist forever with no threat
of defeat sim discovers the sword scam
messages on them he learns that his
father and brother died in the war as
he's reflecting on the Tarly name he
looks heart's been and notices the
Valyrian encryptions the animal had to
translate all of the swords he is the
only one fluent in mullerian tongue in
Westeros we've learned that Don reads
the night is dark and full of terror
when winter falls it falls forever bran
will had to fight the mountain after all
he and Jamie get tests we trying to
steal Don off of the Iron Throne he will
decapitate the mountain but he doesn't
die there bran will die the hints of the
mountain once they get back to
Winterfell the hound kills the mountain
later was the night King turns the
mountain into white Walker The Hound
uses the flaming sword and feeds his
brother this is also her Jaime will
choke Cersei to death a stark must be
Minerva this is due to the pact between
men and the children and the others
Winterfell is attack captured or
threatened the king of the night will
seek revenge the pact was broken with
him captured and Ramsay burned minivan
and drove out the remaining Starks
general defeat the night king in the
crypts were little fingers dagger cat's
paw the knocking you will then use
bazarian to kill himself and Jon Snow
IVs area will just and crushing himself
in the night king to death Jon will rise
from the rubble unburned and live John
George a me and Hound will be the only
main care
survivors the Valerians will come to
Westeros from lantus to issue them new
house names and new swords there are
tests with passing down the truth three
generations to follow work together now
it does sound interesting but we don't
know if this is just a fanfiction or
legit leaked however many of you seem to
think it might be real and I have that
made it sounds like nothing we have
heard as far since no one ever expected
is to be the nat king shoe motivation as
well as the orion steel swords having
instructions of how to defeat the net
kinging raved into it some fans believe
this to be legit plot leaked now let's
analyze it starting with the first point
well it means those swords have all been
engraved in Valyrian with instructions
so how to end the long night which are
pieces of a poem
along with dragonglass valerian still is
one of the known substances that can
kill by walkers and it allegedly
contains instructions of how to feed the
night king aside from its sharpness
strength and lightweight Valyrian steel
is also recognizable by distinctive
ripple pattern visible in blades made
from it here this pattern is actually
part of a poem that would end a long
night it then continues with its sword
forged an Iron Throne has instructions
on how to prevent a long night by
working together firstly it says that
Valyrian steel swords have all been
engraved in Valyrian with instructions
so how to end a long night you know it
says that swords forged and yarn thrown
also have instructions but not how to
end it but rather how to prevent it by
working together is this supposed to
mean that the Iron Throne is made of
Valyrian steel or is it just a metaphor
instructions working together as one the
Iron Throne is not made of Valyrian
steel but it could have become alluring
and still in the process of its forging
the secret of forging Valyrian steel was
lost in the doom of Valyria after which
creating new mullerian steel weapons
became impossible stories claimed that
the metal was imputed magic spells and
forged with dragon fire the Iron Throne
was forged at the order of the Aegon the
conquerer the first of the Targaryen
Kings who conquered six of the seven
independent kingdoms on Westeros and
unified them under his rule the seventh
kingdom of Dorne was later joined
through a marriage alliance the throne
was allegedly forged from one thousand
swords that had been surrendered to a
gun in the war of confessed but the
Lord's sweat offered her filthy although
the actual number of the swords is less
than 200 this recipe currently melted
down by the fiery breath of a concierge
on balerion the black dread then baron
and bent into a throne of imposing
appearance
so the 200 blades Sagan used in its
making were just ordinary steel he then
melted them down with dragon fire now
let's get back to how many believe the
Valyrian steel was made it metal imbued
with magic spells but magic an Forge
with dragon fire perhaps they aren't
when became Bolivian steel during its
forging but they're just my thought
anyways in this alleged plot point the
iron throne is either Valyrian steel or
it's just supposed to be a metaphor
prevent along night by sticking together
working together on to the next point it
says net heat down inside of the Iron
Throne with tighter swords and it will
be shown in the flashback hiding the
sword before Robert storms in and the
night King knows Dawn has the final
piece of the poem to end the long night
that's why he's marching south he's
looking for the sword to destroy it so
he can exist forever with no threat of
defeat some few months ago i theorize
dawn will be the weapon to end the night
king the defeat of the night king lies
in the oldest most famous and most
magical sword of Westeros dawn the
living would literally bring the dawn
with dawn here it says that Don would
not literally be used to kill tonight
King but it rather contains the final
piece of the poem to end the long night
which I like even more no matter if the
sleek turns out to be real or not I
still believe that the legendary sword
dawn will play a big role in the fear in
the night King and ending the long night
as I think it's the only weapon capable
of killing the night king and bringing
the dawn name of the store being dawn
and a title it gives being the sword of
the morning is what seals the deal for
me it's name in the title it gives in my
opinion for shadows that dawn will in
fact be used to kill the night king by
the new sword of the morning : the long
night bring the new morning or as most
Angie would say it the princess promise
still will the sword Lightbringer and
will bring the dawn it also says the
winner fell and all full blooded Starks
had to perish to end the long night for
good and apparently them showing
Winterfell burning was an actual league
from the showrunners a meaningful
burning will in fact take place in the
last episode and nothing the terror does
feel expected I don't know what to think
about this one like photos seem to
suggest that the final battle will take
place in his landing and not in
Winterfell
but then again there's a slight chance
of us being wrong or even misled by a
few fake scenes however I still believe
in our fell burning it will take place
in episode 3 since the night king is
definitely conquering Winterfell in that
episode again I could be wrong and this
plot point could be correct but that's
just my thought it then says that sand
discovers the source here messages on
and he learns that his father and
brother died in the war as he's
reflecting on the Tarly name he looks
cards benin notices the valerian
encryptions this is the part I like the
most and part I can actually see
happening if there's something engraved
into Valyrian steel then it's definitely
going to be same who'll find it out
perhaps that is the real reason and real
importance of same taking the Valyrian
sword of his family Sam is not a fighter
Samuel not use it to kill by walkers he
might give it to someone to use it in
such way like to draw for example but
the entire story of Sam taking hearts
pain just to give it to someone to fight
the dead would not make much sense nor
would it give any porns to the story
Sam learning something from it on the
other hand would do just the opposite it
would complete same taking heart pain
story and it would serve as Sam's final
and most important part that he has to
play in the Great War
here he discovers that the source have
messages on him a poem which phlearn diz
the poem to end the long night
then it states that Danny will have to
translate all of the swords and she is
the only one fluent in Valyrian tongue
in Westeros at the moment this is not
correct as both man Sanjay who come back
to Westeros and me saying they are also
fluent in malaria in Westeros but then
again they might be dead at that point
bleeding they need the only one who can
read it we've learned that the final
piece of poem Don reads the night is
dark and full of terror when meteor
falls it falls forever
the next point includes brought in the
mountain will apparently fight it says
that bran and Jamie get test they trying
to steal dawn off of the Iron Throne we
always get to see these stones
submissions and to be honest there's
none better than brown and Jaime for
this mission since none on skin's
landing in the red cape as these two
allegedly Brown will decapitate the
mountain but he doesn't die there and
the mountain will in fact he'll bran
once they get back to Winterfell
The Hound kills the mountain when the
night King turns the mountain into white
Walker The Hound uses flaming sword and
defeats his brother this is also where
Jamie will choke Cersei to death here
the Hound will finally overcome his fear
of fire and burn his brother to death
this of course will hit the story of the
kill game brothers come full circle the
mountain is the one who burned hound so
it would be sort of a poetic justice to
see the Hound get his vengeance by
burning his brother there's not much to
say about Jaime killing sir say that's
not already been said in my previous
videos the Jaime already realized who
his sister truly is a man she grows
fully mad when she becomes the mad queen
Jaime will have to put an end to her and
once
again saved thousands of innocent people
the next we learn why the night king
decided to march south for don't know
and its allegedly because the stark must
always be Minerva this is due to the
pact between men and the children and
the others even FL is attacked or
captured the king of the night will seek
revenge the pact was broken mantheon
captured and Ramsay burned Winterfell
ensure while the remaining stars and
finally we'll learn how it all ends
Johnny feeds the night king in the
crypts with cat's paw the night king
will then use Viserion to kill himself
and Jon Snow along but Jon Snow will
rise from the rubble and burned and life
they've already seen Jon burn in the
very first season and you already know
my opinion when someone claims that Jon
cannot burn however there's a huge
amount of fans who believe Jon cannot
burn anymore ever since his resurrection
fans explained John dies as dark and
rose as a Targaryen which in my opinion
still doesn't mean anything since
Targaryen skin and do burn all except
for Danny but I don't know this plot
point doesn't make sense to me but
that's just me it finishes with stating
that John George Amon the count will be
the only main cast survivors the
Valerians will come to Westeros from
Lannister issued a new house names and
new swords they are tasked with passing
down the truth to each of their
generations to follow work together what
happened to Dana Tyrion brain sends Arya
and everyone else it did say that all
the Starks had to perish for the long
night to be over
but I cannot believe Jon would kill
siblings I personally don't think this
is how a game turns to end there might
be some truth to this plot lake but it's
definitely not how well things will play
out brain for example is not even
mentioned and he's the one who's the
most important in bringing the night
king down also there are too many main
characters for jean-georges Amy and
Hound being the only one left alive in
conclusion this plot leak in my opinion
might have some truth to it but I really
doubt all of this will happen especially
the way it ends the points I could see
happen are don't being important in
bringing the end of the night king Sam
learning something of a huge importance
the count killing the mountain with fire
Jaime killing stars say and some
connection between the Starks of
Winterfell and the night king let me
know your thoughts about this alleged
leak in the comment section down below
do you believe it's real or fake and
which points could you actually see
happening and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace